how's it going bros my name is p.m. yeah
like a my cousin Ione with this
crazy-ass Consuela yes um I have a fake
I know hot today I miss you Sharon I'm
pretty sure we're in this friggin castle
whatever hello we need one of those how
I was sure we need one of those friggin
statues and push it downstairs
I think at least it's just my intuition
all right whatever let's find a statue
and they get the heck out of here okay
let's see her I think ah [ __ ] it
ah I'm so [ __ ] let's jam jam or
activate it work Shan will never works
burst oh never ever work okay miss that
show guys
I know I know I know it's solve it head
see see what okay it's got to be
overhead see see No okay good it has to
be I know I know it's head yes okay
you're gonna push you ha penny okay try
to push you nah wait what
don't take it away from me get back it
stupid statue gotta run from me [ __ ]
do you sure that's what she's it this is
the end of land for you [ __ ]
okay this is spot alright so we gotta
pick up a family item blue star okay so
we need to go to the fireplace not I'm
gonna do a say cry three a dilemma so
you file three you have an older browser
recognizes video while since I did my
same Syrian lmao
I don't you where's the fireplace
where's fireplace where is it here
nah where's the stupid fire bladers keep
looking but they never fire
I'd say that's it huh okay wait I don't
even need a fireplace
you make me ha but stop it sorry all
right yeah okay we're good nah Apollo
look at that ah Susan uh-oh
buck buck buck buck but I hate game or I
won't have time to get over in this
playthrough that was last wait do we
have the item now we don't course not
quite the nice save I swear see all
right I think I think I'm better right
there we go stop it so stupid
okay and that NAS really gets confusing
I'm don't don't judge me all right I
know you're sitting there like I just
let's not have it okay it's a probably
obvious I'll I'll I'm in it's probably
uh nah
okay here ah here it is here it is nice
okay get up guys so now we're gonna put
the redstone no no no no no no I'm gonna
put the blue stone see see how did you
happy now yeah Oh sad face oh we have
his head
hiiii okay no what am i doing can I put
the head to head okay mr. shirt
mister do that you murderer you know
that ah it was me pretty effort you're a
freakin but I am i hey that exactly good
it's actually cool vocals I mean
I [ __ ] hate you breakfast all right
Robert miss dish yeah you're so crazy
killing people
oh uh all right
um now we're gonna move ahead no wait no
no now we're not gonna move the head
well I would just read it but what
someone wrote in the college the
highest-rated comment by cool crazy gal
one I get the brush-off remove all side
restaurant net shares and then some 100
doll with no I have to get head faces
light ball with a head was oh I know
that
okay let's go over here then we're gonna
put the light bulb I am this is freakin
sky yup that makes sense
all right and then let's just say hi
okay now no way did you go outside Jesus
Christ look at that just look at that
sick odorous ha ha
I [ __ ] her ah let's do stoplight
charm
ha ha not sex face
but what what's a locked I'll do it
ah you know I know has to be behind that
is mr. share I can't believe did that
okay that's the spring huh
what I got it no I don't got it
all right someone said do it backwards
all right hello
Oh moving mad I won't worry all right
I'm going left
uh-huh and then I'm all right
uh-huh uh-huh no no that's impossible
wait I know yes yes yes I'm suck and I'm
suck now is ah man okay what about is si
si no I did i hi Caramba
I
return B bottom escape zero key all
right
why do I always start with that one that
never works right now she get out now
your phone so brother right about now
the [ __ ] it's impossible now okay what
about this
ah okay so apparently you're not
supposed to solve the puzzle you just
posed to put stupid on it and you brush
add in a comment I you pedicle I need a
key
okay wait there [ __ ] wait he's
then alright I think it's two five eight
holy [ __ ] my memories the best thing
ever if I do this okay it's not I think
you bros knew that all right okay let's
just do this and then I don't but I am
already hip is up the Paul was in this
game don't ever go again I can't do it
I'm tired I just can't I thought my best
I swear I do it I do it for you but no
you don't ever thank me by doing it was
pretty [ __ ] close it was very very
dogs you have to say that okay oh I was
in here okay I got this kissing my bad
my voice cuz I'm pissed
okay five today right - nine - sorry
fine and amazement key all right we got
what okay hey what are you doing let's
poke him for the flag game ah okay my I
would I should say yep I should say oh
he's so sexy enough holy [ __ ] he says Oh
mister sure you're a champion
ha hey do you know what I did charmant
that's why I was like this share mode
activated fun that's all I did
okay whatever okay oh yeah I caught him
let's go to the basement
holy [ __ ] hey wait welcome in here
wait have you been here oh yeah back in
from first wait isn't it segment where's
the basement
hey I don't know what is amazing hi guys
got to be here right now
oh oh down share some harsh okay let's
go here bros use a basement key I don't
like this alright okay whatever it's
dark I don't even care hey okay what's
going on here mr. chair
what are you doing here mr. Shannon hi
there's no light that I neither like
that I mean I have a like that but I mr.
Sharon we're in big trouble big trouble
Cher okay I think it's so dark it's so
what happened
okay another puzzle whatever I've done
with his [ __ ] puzzles all right I'm
gonna any hair bros see you tomorrow ha
ha
all right I'm just gonna go pick up my
batteries